hey how's it going best bow get that
[ __ ] out don't watch TV breath - but I'm
back anyway I've we're in this new area
it kind of looks like penumbra
I feel really short where's the shower
looks small Patti I dieted good misty
sure I lost maybe five minutes of
recording I'm sorry I know you hate when
it happens I hate what happened Joe but
really nothing happened we just entered
here and
story-wise basically someone is [ __ ]
with our dreams and that's why I've
caused their lose Nations we're gonna go
in here I'm not cheated I just
telepathically don't do it today there
whenever I shut up ounce
died one dead night I tried for so long
to get this [ __ ] to work alright you
coming with me this charity I love you
make out with me hey let's shout out so
far I perish now we can open these doors
later barrel Arafat later barrel you can
hang out with a good way to cool I'm
gonna die to be extra yeah high quality
version quality in day especially when
it come to
with you and me and all right what
someone just came through a trombone I
think yes where's mr. Scheck oh hell no
oh hell no all right it's fine I have
this really ugly Rock well [ __ ] I don't
[ __ ] Oh get away from me Rock
all right ma come on
hello I work fine this is it oh [ __ ] I'm
so [ __ ]
so [ __ ] that's a fact that's about
[ __ ] y'all I ain't got time for you door
refrigerator come here huh I feel better
now
all right what do we got nothing nada
niente watch our back
that's right it's that blood come
alright what's going here I don't even
know what's going on
oh yeah my closets I like them well [ __ ]
these rooms then I gotta investigate I
have to investigate I feel bad if I
don't more refrigerators yeah what do I
do
[ __ ] you what Billy Mays okay let's find
then how's that
oh [ __ ] ah what am i doing [ __ ] Billy
Mays isn't he the guy who died that's
not cold man
alright oh don't bother [ __ ] locked
why do I do it then
okay we'll go over here where Billy Mays
went should I go with a bit of a sweat
no I'm gonna go forward I don't like
Willie Mays just kidding I love him
it's barely sexy the blood lays behind
the store this can't be good well it's
not open as word as if you ask me
that a dick I can totally touch it it
what is that what is that what are you
doing down there dick fine see if I care
Billy I'm sure he went here no dicks in
that one I don't know about this Prez hi
every [ __ ] door right come on what am
I supposed to do
I gots this safar Accord why are you
ding ling that's what she said such an
overused joke bidding
don't do it fine I don't do it boxes
Billy do something seriously Billy
but why in the heavens without white
pants I did Billy Mays go I'm not gonna
cheat
okay I'm seriously not gonna cheat I
take that back I changed my mind I'm not
gonna take vows do you hide something
from me
I'm sure I missed something I mean it
doesn't make any sense
I think I maybe missed the key somewhere
[Music]
this is really annoying when you have to
walk around for so long and you get you
get you get down oh there you are got
damaged restaurant key that's perfect I
would have needed that this is the
restroom I wish you'd told me what it
was at least all right here we go
it goes nothing breasts yeah [ __ ] yeah
let's go
parry it everywhere bring it Shamma
Lamma you [ __ ] you what do you do that
why you're not funny
Jesus Christ I hate when they do that
tige right out type [ __ ] writer what
is this place what it what that's my
skype I'm sorry what is this
slice is this supposed to be me
if that
I'm not bald and I don't think my penis
looks like that it's way bigger hmm what
all right all right penny jaesik I had
to use this fake pee while you were gone
all right fine we can go and I pull that
lemon over there it's fine I'll do it
holy [ __ ] what I all did I just do you
solve the peasant baby no way about it
all right I like this I like this every
day
yeah I can imagine all right let's drop
this ow
Jace's guys I have not missed I didn't I
get a key or something oh maybe I can go
in here now oh I like of this missing
special heads all right caution is
advised pants all right what is this
blue light I like it
whoa [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
don't worry about it I got it under
control whatever you say man the [ __ ] is
this
okay Oh what does that moanin
it's probably your mom's pissing what
don't say that's about a half yeah I
would know because I've seen it what
pets what are you saying okay I
definitely don't like this let's just
get all the generator and get the [ __ ]
out
all right I got it but oh [ __ ] run pen
don't look back today what am I gonna do
I got this no problem
ah [ __ ] don't worry about it you are
faster identify all right we're good
I don't even know what I need this five
pins not even wait a minute but it's
this but that door closed by itself I
don't know what I feel about that then
why does a hanging man going I put you
down there
it's like you're sleeping I guess we're
going here now and we use this no totes
oh I know we need to go go back what was
that sound I don't give a [ __ ] how do I
peds got going geez but nothing darling
that's what she said right feather god
damn it shut up alright we're going back
we're going way back in time back in
time back in time they say we all right
put you down
all right I'll see you later don't worry
my pets I'll stay here don't get lost
like he always says to father Jesus
Christ all right
well gee burrows didn't see - whoa
over here is a machine room and I guess
that's what we need these for God Evan
can you walk in this Lord
yeah yeah yeah yeah happier
this one says one and this one says one
so let's say put you there why not
seriously why not seriously why the [ __ ]
not
don't [ __ ] with me now you little penis
hole why not
what is this three battle-ax why why why
why why why not why not do it what do
what do what what do you what dad no
comprendo
well no
what is this place oh ma I can do bad a
night I can do do do do
[Music]
why can I pick this up alright there we
go alright alright this is for not
working I totally failed there where is
it
hey why baby where did you shut up go
let it fix it nah what am I supposed to
do then shut up shut up shut up
what about these generators huh alright
I'm not gonna cheat or anything hmm
alright so without cheating or anything
because I don't think I don't need to
cheat cheating is for losers that's what
mama always said and that's why I always
never cheat Mike don't look at me like
that okay I cheated a happy okay I
didn't cheat we need to go in here I had
a sense about it I had it good sense
good vibe you never had good vibes you
never had a wide good
good good vibrations that give you a
good vibe I bet it did didn't it
I bet you liked it that is really weird
I okay Wow all right six new I'm not
gonna click that I'm gonna follow the
period like my mama always said my mama
said a lot thank deena hi Brad whoa
while working on the product we found a
hidden temple deep underground it was a
starving place where what with some of
the workers found remain dead people
bone the nose covered in blood I can
jump up alright what do we get what are
we going
open Sam alright it's gonna be a key
here uno dos tres don't this this but no
key are you serious come on come on come
on come on come on typewriter throw your
worst ah no nothing
well then dude guess why don't you just
[ __ ] open all right I'll use this
I'll use it
come on
what do you
[Music]
Wow I'm not gonna cheat there anything
is that hmm all right so without
cheating of course I found mmm thank I
get out of wait what is this
are you hiding favor I'm sorry I'm so
fat I know you I what is this explain
this [ __ ] explain this mr. chair
hahaha I like it when I'm out no just
kidding
III it's dangerous that you shouldn't go
to that page okay pity I tell you I've
got it
don't worry about it I know what I'm
doing I'm an expert how the hell did I
do that
No get down what nice I love the
wallpaper [ __ ] [ __ ] move my entire
deck I did not expect that you good son
of a [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
lot of jump is Gary zyer have a gun what
is this
alright I'm gonna end this episode
Stefano what are you doing in here and
that's bathing what Jason Scott I was
hiding something fight why were you
hiding that why would he wet dive
escaping a fire I was giving a sex on
the Basques
darlings episode ever it's like every
fiend I gotta come with Ray J on the
same
to me
oh sure
brutality